yes what was the question she asked if
we eat ass yeah I do I eat ass yeah
I was skeptical for a long time oh I
don't have to tell you why I think it's
pretty obvious the only only
really has one order of business you
know what I mean but my buddy told me he
was like you know vanilla extract I go
yeah
he goes it smells good but it tastes
terrible I go yeah he goes the asshole's
the opposite
he owes us your bodies with a little
extract it smells terrible but it tastes
pretty good
but he wasn't that far off I have
friends of mine who do that like they'll
meet somebody at a bar I'm like no no we
got to know each other for a while when
I go to your house you have like I
showered this morning at eight cool hit
it again yeah
especially in Miami here where it's damp
you just can't beat
you sweat walking houses that is gonna
be a salty situation that you're not
going to want to be part of